well sarah the politics here is
gathering pace after those very dramatic
events
last week which saw the capitol building
stormed by
trump's supporters now the democrats
were hoping
to introduce a resolution into the house
calling as you heard on mike pence the
vice president to introduce the 25th
amendment which would force uh donald
trump from
office it's basically an amendment to
the constitution which if a president is
physically
or mentally incapable of dispensing his
duties
uh he has to get out of the way in this
case of course it would be his mental
capacity
to be president of the united states
they were hoping for unanimity
that was blocked by the republicans so
what's happened now you've seen
the adjournment it will go back uh to
the floor tomorrow at 9 00 a.m where
there'll be
a vote on it and we'll see whether it
passes then
in the meantime we understand they've
also introduced a resolution
for impeachment against donald trump
that will be voted on we think
on wednesday it just needs a simple
majority and if that happens of course
donald trump will be in the ignominious
position of being
the first president ever to be impeached
twice um of course there are big
questions about the timetable of all of
that
it will get through the house of
representatives but what happens when it
gets to
the senate of course by the time it's
actually dealt with
donald trump will no longer be the
president of the united states
the senate doesn't reconvene until the
19th of january conventionally what
happens is the articles of impeachment
go to the senate they sit on it for a
day and then it goes for the floor
which would be the 20th of january the
day of the inauguration when
president-elect
joe biden becomes the next president of
the united states
interestingly one theory is that they
may sit on those articles of impeachment
and nancy pelosi won't push them over to
the senate
until joe biden has had his first 100
days he can choose the people he wants
to surround himself with
and also get his agenda off the ground
without it being overshadowed by the
specter
of uh donald trump and the accusations
against him of
treason high crimes and misdemeanors